wir machen geschwind weiter mit der
These von Soziologie
ja die europäische und deutsche
Flüchtlingspolitik ist todkrank und muss
dringend und grundlegend reformiert
werden warum ist diese Politik dort
krank erstens und am wichtigsten sie
jagt mehr Menschen in den Tod als dass
sie Menschenleben rettet sind in den
letzten 10 Jahren über 25.000 Menschen
gestorben im Mittelmeer beim Versuch
Europa zu erreichen ähm zweitesten
zweitens die Menschen die Europa
erreichen sind oft nicht die die unsere
Schutz am meisten brauchen europaweit
wird fast die Hälfte der asylsuche
abgewiesen und unter denen die wohl
anerkannt werden sind junge Männer
gesunde junge Männer aus relativ gesehen
wohl haben den Familien weil man muss ja
nicht Schlepper zahlen können deutlich
überrepräsentiert also Frauen alte
kranke oder auch Menschen aus
fluchtregionen von Roses kein Weg nach
Europa führt wie zum Beispiel der Jemen
die bleiben auf der Strecke
drittens für die aufnehmende
Gesellschaften
sorgt die herrschende Asylpolitik für
große integrations- und
Sicherheitsprobleme also die
Arbeitsmarkt auf Partizipation von
Flüchtlingen bleibt sehr stark zurück
sehr schleppend es hat auch damit zu tun
dass das meistens plötzlich ganz viel
auf einmal nach Deutschland
schwer ist die in den Arbeitsmarkt zu
integrieren und die Tatsache dass die
indikationsschwerfe läuft und das nur
ein Teil der Asylsuchende auch
tatsächlich schutzbedürftig die hier
sind und so anerkannt werden sorgt dafür
dass vor allem gute diejenigen nicht
anerkannt werden werden sehr hohe
Kriminalitätsrate haben die sie vor
allem auch in der Gewaltkriminalität
äußert was ist ihre Lösung
meine Lösung ist dass wir Umsteuern
müssen von der irregulären Migration die
jetzt die europäische Szene dominiert zu
einer regulierten Migration weil ah wir
brauchen Migration für den Arbeitsmarkt
wurde schon angesprochen wir haben
Arbeitskräftemangel wir haben
demografische Gruppe 400.000 pro
Fachkräfte ja wir brauchen natürlich
nicht jede Art von Zuwanderung das ist
das ist das ist klar also wir brauchen
diese regulierte Zuwanderung und wir
haben auch da stehe ich hundertprozentig
dazu wir haben auch humanitäre
Verpflichtungen also wenn man über
Jahrzehnte betrachtet wie viel
Flüchtlinge Europa aufnimmt dann ist das
nicht mehr als in anderen Regionen der
Welt Afrika Asien und so weiter es ist
nur so dass wir in Europa das Problem
haben plötzlich kommen ganz viele und
dann haben wir Jahre lang da kommen fast
keine hierher und dann kommt plötzlich
wieder ganz viele und das führt zu
diesem Integration zu
sicherheitsproblement also wir müssen
aus meiner Sicht das führt nichts dran
vorbei dass man Abkommen macht mit
Drittstaaten und dass man dafür sorgt
dass Menschen die sich irregulär an
europäischen Grenzen melden dass die
zwar ein Recht auf Asyl haben aber
dieses Asylrecht in Drittstaaten
verwirklichen müssen also zum Beispiel
Tunesien oder Albanien oder Marokko muss
man natürlich mit diesen Ländern
verhandeln die müssen natürlich auch die
internationalen Konventionen und so
weiter einhalten und wenn wir das machen
dann können wir auch die Menschen helfen
die es tatsächlich am meisten brauchen
indem wir flüchtlingskontingente
aufnehmen direkt aus dem Krisenregionen
dann würden wir genau das gleiche machen
was Länder wie Kanada oder Australien
machen und dann wissen wir auch dass
wenn die Leute zu uns kommen dass das
tatsächlich schutzbedürftige sind sie
brauchen keine langwierige Asylverfahren
mehr zu durchlaufen können gleichen die
ihre Interaktion anfangen und für die
Akzeptanz auch der
flüchtlingszuwanderung in der
Bevölkerung wird das in ganz großen
Unterschied machen das ist alles richtig
neu darüber diskutieren wir über 10
Jahren und alles was Sie gerade jetzt
gesagt haben hat Herr Seehofer schon
vorgeschlagen als noch Innenministerin
Durchführung von Asylverfahren in
Drittstaaten ist sicherlich an nur eine
neue Idee sie ist nicht weltweit neu
erst Australien hat es schon erfolgreich
sind jetzt dabei das durchzuführen und
man kann über die Detail streiten also
großbritannien will das mit Ruanda zu
tun das ist vielleicht nicht das meist
geeignete Land aber das Prinzip stimmt
weil die Menschen die zu uns kommen ich
mache jetzt eine Ausnahme für diejenigen
die direkt aus einem Kriegsgebiet in die
EU fliehen wie z.B die Ukraine oder in
den 90er Jahren die Bosnier aber alle
andere sind schon mindestens in einem
anderen ein meistens sind mehreren
anderen Staaten gewesen wo sie nicht
verfolgt wurden und wo sie nicht
Bürgerkriegen ausgesetzt waren also ich
möchte diese Menschen können wir nicht
unbegrenzt aufnehmen
das konsequent missachtet wird fertig
für Schätze sehr was sie sagen aber ich
kann mich wiederholen das doppelabkommen
ist Abkommen für die Verteilung
innerhalb der EU das wissen wir wir
haben es vorher schon auch das jemand
der schon in einem Drittstaat war der
sicher ist nicht sich das folgenden Land
aussuchen kann in das er Liebe gehen
möchte dass jemand der nach Roman
Rumänien angeht zugewiesen wurde nicht
dann sagen kann ich hätte aber Dänemark
lieber gehabt das war auch Teil des
Tablet Abkommen ja ja aber das ist
innerhalb der EU ich spreche jetzt über
die Verlagerung von Asylverfahren in
Drittstaaten damit wir den Anreiz
wegnehmen für Menschen um sich auf
diesen langen und gefährlichen Weg zu
machen und das ist der Grund dass
Menschen gebaute setzen ist dass Sie
wissen Sie wissen sie werden wir haben
dazu Forschung gemacht sie wissen sehr
gut dass es gefährlich ist sie
überschätzen sogar die Gefahren
also die wissen dass sie ein großes
Risiko laufen aber sie wissen auch wenn
ich einmal in Europa bin dann kann ich
auch bleiben ja und diese Anreise müssen
wir wegnehmen und auch das ist schon
lange diskutiert und besprochen worden
und getan hat sich nicht aber er wurde
heute haben sich ja die Kanister in
Brüssel getroffen haben sie noch
Hoffnung ich habe immer Hoffnung ich
habe immer Hoffnung dass es was
schiefgeld was andere geplant haben das
hält mich sozusagen am laufen aber von
dieser Innenministerin erwarte ich gar
nicht schauen sich da haben sich vor
kurzem letzte Woche glaube ich die G20
Staaten getroffen um andere Probleme zu
diskutieren diesen auseinandergegangen
die saßen glaube ich in Delhi und auch
eine Abschluss Erklärung zu vereinbaren
die Probleme sind nicht kompatibel und
die können Sie auch nicht
synchronisieren es gibt keine
Möglichkeit ganz Europa nach einem
Rezept zu behandeln und ich kann nur
sagen wenn ich flüchten werde würde ich
auch nicht nach Bulgarien in Rumänien
gehen wollen also kann man wohl keine
Rumänien deswegen aus der EU
ausschließen kann man nicht aber die
Idee dass man jemanden bewegen kann nach
Rumänien oder Bulgarien zu gehen ist
völlig absurd auch aus Bulgarien
Rumänien gegen Züge und Flugzeuge nach
Deutschland Holland Dänemark und
Schweden also muss man also muss man die
europäischen Außengrenzen was machen das
ist tatsächlich zu spät denn die
Menschen einmal in Japan sind schon mal
da und es gibt zugleich zurzeit große
Probleme den auch nur einen
menschenwürdige Unterkunft zuzuweisen
die hausenden Sporthallen und ins
Ausland weil die unplanbar plötzlich in
ganz großen Zahlen so ist das Leben es
ist unplanbar man kann auch eine kann
eine geplante Flüchtlingspolitik machen
Kultur der Planwirtschaft in Deutschland
mal gegeben hat nicht nur in Deutschland
die ganzen Pläne sind gescheitert genau
regelmäßig nicht so schwer zu sagen wir
nehmen aus Europa jährlich zwei drei
vier 100000 Flüchtling
Seehofer hat eine Obergrenze von 220
eingeführt und sie wird auch Mörder
weniger eingehalten
dieses Doppel von den beiden Herren und
dann würde ich sie gerne fragen wie
könnte man es nur umsetzen mit den
Außengrenzen ist es überhaupt möglich
das haben zumindest einige Innenminister
auch vorgetragen ich habe auch Denis ja
so reden hören damals also das ist
durchaus durchdacht wurden da waren auch
Spezialisten in den beratungsrunden
dabei und die hätten das nicht erzählt
wenn es nicht auch gehen würde da muss
man wahrscheinlich mit den
Maghreb-Staaten zu ganz anderen Newtons
kommen also mit den Verhandlungen führen
sagen so und so würde das Verlaufen das
Verfahren dann gibt's auch dieser
bewerbungsämter oder wie immer das dann
alles funktioniert oder man macht nur
noch über die Botschaften der Länder aus
denen man flieht aus jetzt Kriegsgebiete
mich hat das auch immer getränkt das
kann ich richtig nachvollziehen wieder
jemand einfach im Stich gelassen worden
ist ganz jämmerlich ich habe den oft
bereist bis 2005 und es tut mir am
Herzen weh zu sehen wie da die Leute
einfach verhungern und das ist
wahrlich alle Menschen gleich sind wenn
man schaut wie die ein und wie die
anderen behandelt werden
das haben wir doch gemerkt wir haben es
doch gemerkt als die ukrainischen
Flüchtlinge kam waren die Herzen weit
und offen weil sie blauäugig sind und
blond und die anderen
deswegen weil sie zum europäischen
Kulturkreis gehören weil sie aus einem
Land fliegen dass direkt an der EU
grenzt die Ukraine können nirgendwo
anders hin sie haben die Russland in den
Rücken also klar sind wir die erst
verantwortlich nach Deutschland
das ist der Hauptgrund warum die
Menschen im Fernsehen ist es so
reflektiert worden ich konnte es auch
nachvollziehen menschlich ähm da war
also diese Aufschrei da ne diese
Flüchtlinge werden gerne genommen und
ich glaube auch dass unser Verhältnis zu
diesem Ukraine Russland Krieg ähm der
hat auch sowas märchenhaftes manchmal
sowas erklärtes es gibt nicht 100 % weiß
und 100% Schwarz in dem Fall schon na
ich bin doch nicht sicher oder auch
nicht die Frage diskutieren ich glaube
das ist möglich ist
dass man ein anderes Asylverfahren
wirklich wählt dann müsste aber um das
durchzusetzen zum Beispiel auch wirklich
der Balkan geschlossen in der EU sein da
kann man nicht Griechenland alleine
lassen da unten das geht da nicht
sondern muss man Europa wirklich eine
Außengrenze machen da kann man keine
Enklaven haben oder sowas da muss
überlegen was damit mit mit den ganzen
entschlafen dann noch in auf dem
marktred aber im Kern wäre das möglich
wenn die Europäische Union eine
geschlossene Außengrenze hat und sich so
vereinbart und diese zwei wenn sind
schon zwei sehr große Events ne da muss
noch einiges passieren ich halte das
auch für richtig dass ich die
Europäische Union durchaus in dieser
Frage wie ein großer Staat verhält
genauso wie eine Energiefrage da hatten
wir heute schon drüber gesprochen wäre
auch klug darüber nachzudenken er die in
gemeinsames energieportfolio zu haben
und nicht einen deutschen Sonderweg ne
das kann ich vielleicht ganz kurz sagen
warum keine anders behandelt haben sehr
gerne habe ich wiederhole mich auch sehr
gerne es kam vorwiegend Frauen und
Kindern vielen Dank ja werden wir auch
schon gedacht ja das ist ein guter Punkt
ist nicht angenehm meiner Talkshow auch
mal kommt abzugeben sonst immer nur
gegeneinander Essen
und das zweite ist dass die Migration
über die wir sprechen vor allem aus
jungen kräftigen teilweise gewaltaffinen
Männern besteht ja das ist wahr und dass
ich bis jetzt noch keinen Fall
wahrgenommen habe wo sich eine
ukrainische Mutter mit ihren Kindern in
die Luft gesprengt hatte oder wo sie
sich von Autobahnbrücken abgesagt hätten
und es ist vollkommen richtig dass wir
die Ukraine im positiven Sinne sondern
behandeln ja die gehören zur Familie und
die anderen
und so ist das auch ja ist das auch den
Punkt würde ich gerne aufnehmen und auch
zustimmen denn auch allein emotional ist
es etwas anderes und es ist menschlich
passiert ist vor 55 mm Entfernung 500 km
Entfernung oder 5000 km entfernt und das
ist alleine emotionale und dann kommt
der Punkt neben den Frauen und Kindern
was völlig richtig ist dann kommt der
Punkt das ist um Europa geht ja also es
wird immer um Europa gesprochen meistens
meine die Leute eu-leiter Gottes aber
wenn man ehrlichen europäischen Gedanken
hat dann geht es hier gerade um die
simplen guten tollen Wert von Europa und
das haben sie wiederum völlig recht
währenddessen in vielen Ländern wo
offensichtlich kein Krieg ist zum
Beispiel in Nürnberg kann ich sagen sind
sehr viel äthiopia gekommen zum
damaligen Zeitpunkt gab es in Shopping
keinen Krieg trotzdem ähm gekommen
aufgrund von ja jetzt schon korrekt aber
das nur damalige Zeitpunkt nicht das
heißt man hat und das macht man bis
heute nicht zwischen Migration und
Flüchtlinge unterschieden und da beginnt
das eigentliche Problem da gebe ich ihn
völlig recht das wird nie unterschieden
und das macht die Probleme wurden sie
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie